ALOK CHANDEL: Hello, my
name is Alok Chandel.
I'm a user experience
designer on Project Glass.
Today, we'll be
talking about how
to create some great
experiences on Glass.
We'll look at what are the great
experiences on Glass, and then,
how do you go about
creating some of those?
Let's get right to it.
What are the experiences which
feel right at home on Glass?
Keep the user in the moment.
As a user of Glass, if
I'm walking down a bridge,
I have a question, I ask,
get answered instantly.
What's important on
Glass is that you
allow the user to stay in the
physical world, while still
taking these short, small
dips in the digital world
and continue through
rest of their day.
Voice first.
Now, this is really important.
Because unlike
other devices where
voice may be just
one of the ways
the user interact with it,
on Glass, voice is critical.
It is also fast and a
natural way to interact.
As a Glassware developer,
you will have an opportunity
to provide some voice commands.
When you are doing
such a thing, think
about what are the actions
your users are going
to take to invoke
your Glassware.
Something like "OK, Glass, take
a picture," is a great command.
"OK, Glass, start a
camera," not so much.
Just like any other wearable
device, speed truly matters.
If you can deliver
amazing experiences
in less than five
seconds, they're
just going to become perfect.
If you have a feature-rich
mobile or web application,
think about what are
the specific nuggets
of amazing experiences
you can provide on Glass.
And then you can use voice
or one tap actions for users
to access those.
If you can reduce
the amount of time
between an intent
that the user has
and the action they need to
take to fulfill that intent,
you will be able to create
brilliant Glasswares.
Keep things relevant.
Now, on Glass, you want
to deliver experiences
which are relevant
right down to the moment
user is interacting with them.
If I have a Glassware which
lists all of my shopping list,
and I walk into a
grocery store, show
me only the part of
the shopping list
which I can purchase
in the grocery store.
Something which I'm
going to order online
just doesn't belong on
Glass at that moment.
Understand the context, like
a location, time of day,
day of the week, even
my personal preferences.
Combine all of these to create
some amazing experiences.
The display of the Glass sits
so close to the user's eyes
that you have a
unique opportunity
to create Glassware
which orient to the view
that the user is
having of the world.
Now, it's important,
that when you're
creating these experiences,
that you update the view
the moment user is
turning their head.
Now, that's how you
create good experiences.
What makes these
experiences even better
are if you can use either voice
or head gestures to free up
the hands, so that
the users can interact
with the world around them.
Let's summarize what are the
experiences which work great
on Glass.
Those who keep the
user in the moment.
Those who use voice for quick
and natural interactions.
Make sure that
experiences of delivering
the right amount of information
at just the right time, that
orient to the view of
the world around me.
And finally, free
up my hand so that I
can interact with
the world around me.
In the next section,
let's take a look
at some of the
recommendations on how
to create some
great experiences.
Let's start with typography.
On Glass, the default
system font is Roboto.
We use two weights of
this font, thin and light.
When you look at
all the templates,
40 pixel is the font
size we use almost
as a regular or
normal font size.
You can increase it to
50, something like large,
or 70 pixel, like an
extra large font size.
Anything larger
than this may not
give you enough space on
Glass to write full sentences.
However, you may be
able to use larger font
sizes for very specific
pieces of information.
For example, temperature
or sports scores.
Let's take a look at the
other end of the spectrum.
If you go down to 34 pixel font
size, think of it as small.
30 pixel, extra small.
Anything smaller than
this in the body text,
it's just not going to
be legible for a user.
So stay away from those sizes.
Let's look at a very important
facet of designing really,
really good and legible
Glassware-- padding.
You'll notice that
all of our templates
will have 40 pixel
padding on all sides.
Now, this is important so
that the content that you're
putting in front
of the user doesn't
get clipped on the
left or the right side.
Similarly, this will allow
some of the system UIs
like scroll bar or progress
bar to easily occupy
this 40 pixel space without
interacting with the content
that you're presenting
to the user.
The closer you can
present the content
to the center of the
screen, the easier
it will be for a
user to focus on it.
Let's take a look at some of the
core templates that we provide.
This is a basic template.
Really good for putting
in a lot of text which
is still digestible on Glass.
One important thing that you'll
notice on all the templates
is there is a space
provided to put in metadata.
Now, this metadata
allows the user
to understand who is
providing this content,
and also, what is the context
in which this content is
being provided.
Another template,
we call it Otter.
This is great for both providing
who is the sender, as well
as the subject line, of
course, in addition to
the body of the message.
There are tons of
other templates
which you can find at
our developer website
that deal with things like
lists, full-bleed images, et
cetera.
Glanceable UIs.
Now, this is an important part.
Glass is a device which is
designed from grounds up
to be used out and about.
When you are presenting the
user an information which
is divided up into lots of small
chunks, really start thinking,
can you actually
spread this information
across couple of
different screens?
Can you reduce this
information into something
which is much more
easily digestible?
So, for example, if
I change this screen
to something like
this, all of a sudden
it is much more easy for me
to read this information even
when I'm jogging.
If you are able to reduce
the number of chunks down
to just one without diminishing
the value of information,
you may actually have a
truly great Glassware.
Low density, high quality.
Now, you may have created
some great experiences
on mobile and web using
responsive design.
If you want to scale down
those designs on Glass
and expect that those
experiences are going to work,
you may not actually
have that much luck.
If you want to create
experience on Glass
think about creating
them from grounds up.
There are certain
experiences which
work especially beautiful,
especially nice on Glass.
Things like full-bleed images.
Again, make use of the
space provided for metadata
to make sure that the
user is understanding what
is the context in which
this image is being provided
to them.
The last point here, and
this is really important.
When you are creating
experiences on Glass,
make sure that you are testing
it both indoors and outdoors.
Now, it is important
because some colors
may look different
on Glass compared
to how they look on
your computer monitor.
This happens because Glass
is a transparent display.
A color like black may
actually be just transparent.
White may actually provide you
with the max amount of contrast
to improve the
legibility of your text.
Make sure that you
are truly testing
all of your UIs, both
indoors and outdoors.
Let's recap some of
the recommendations
we talked about.
Use proper typography.
If you have your own brand
related fonts, use them.
But make sure that
they are following
the guidelines we talked about.
Similarly, make sure that you're
using the standard templates,
or at least using
them as guidelines
to create really rich, nice,
legible content on Glass.
Make sure that the content
you are presenting to a user
is in small bite-size chunks
that they can easily digest.
And lastly, make sure that
every single interface
you're creating on Glass, you
test both indoors and outdoors.
As you go about creating
some amazing Glassware,
think about what can you do on
Glass which can be done better
on Glass than any other device?
At the same time, think
about some of the things
we talked about in this talk.
Create the content
which is relevant
right down to the moment.
Use voice for fast and
natural interactions.
Work with some of the
standard patterns and styles
to create truly
useful Glassware.
And finally, the better
you can do these things
together, the better the
experience for your users
is going to be.
We have some amazing
documentation
on our developer website,
which you can take a look.
At the same time,
make sure that you
continue exploring more and more
ways in which you can create
amazing experiences
for your users.
Thank you very much.